and I've gotten a little action on
Twitter
apparently some folks don't like me say
Merry Christmas but um you know I I
don't carry I mean I've got it one of my
good friends as rabbi Daniel lapin he's
an Orthodox Jewish rabbi he always says
Happy Hanukkah and it doesn't offend me
he's Jewish that's what he should say
I'm not offended he's not offended wanna
say Merry Christmas by the way cuz he's
not walking around with a chip on his
shoulder so trying to correct my speech
or anything like that and it you guys
sometimes I gotta stop and you know
Merry Christmas this is a fun time of
year
that's me people are walking around just
mad about everything look like you were
weaned on a pickle or something I mean
it's just why y'all so mad about
everything and so upset and so torn up
some of you my goodness gracious just
lighten up a little bit have a good time
have an eggnog you'll be all right it's
um stay out of the mall I don't make you
mad man just trying to park that's
enough to call you don't have to get on
the interstate to get road rage just go
the mall parking lot that'll do it I
don't go the mall parking lot except
there is a mall right across from our
offices and there's a whole lot of
people over there which makes it kind of
hard to get into the office and some
aren't happy y'all and then amazing hey
guys that this is the time for hope it's
a time for faith it's a time for love
and people are just all twisted up and
if you want this show to be politically
correct you're gonna have a problem I
help anybody I don't care what you do I
mean I accept if you're calling him you
cuss or something we'll hang up on your
if you're just stupid and after I'll try
to help you for a little while I'll hang
up on you but you know but more than
that I'll help anybody I'm not mad at
you regardless of where you come from or
if you believe something that's
different than I believe that's fine
I'll help you with your money it's what
we do here but if you if you just help
you with us a little bit right across
the front of show it says the Dave
Ramsey show which means two things if
you're smart number one it means I own
it so I'm gonna do with it what I want
number two it means it's kind of what
Dave Ramsey thinks about crap you know I
mean so if you want to call up and find
out what somebody else thinks about
something you shouldn't call
because I can't help you with that but I
am an expert on my opinion and I can
help you with that so it's what we do
here y'all and and you know when we show
folks how to get out of debt and show
how to show them how to get control of
their own destiny and to believe again
in a desired future you know what that
does it rekindles hope inside their
lives and not because I gave them hope I
don't have the ability to give you hope
I can show you things you can do in your
life that show you are a control are in
control of your life and you know when
you have a sense that you control the
variables that you control your destiny
that's what gives you hope because you
have a positive hope is a positive
belief about the future that's all hope
is it's a positive belief about the
future and turns out no one can give you
that I can show you a future that's
pretty cool and if you believe in it
then that gives you hope I can say hey
if you took these three steps you'll be
out of debt you won't have a car payment
you wouldn't have a student loan you're
gonna be winning again and so some
people got confused man they thought
that you know Trump was gonna bring hope
and Obama didn't have hope or Obama had
hope and Trump didn't have hope
if hope is that the White House we're
screwed it doesn't live there hope was a
baby in a manger 2,000 years ago hope is
not in the White House nor will it be
coming to the White House it does you
know it you you could if your hope is
based on nothing less than Trump or
Obama and their righteousness you're up
a creek really and so you guys talk to a
friend of my other day in the your case
I'm so scared I want you scared of you
the only reason you would be scared is
if you believe that the White House
won't has more power than it has and you
don't believe in the guy coming in to
the White House you know and some people
run around well what Michelle said on
Oprah told Oprah or something hope is
gone hopes like Oh Michelle it wasn't
placed in you darling
I'm sorry motus or whatever we call the
what do we call the first lady FLOTUS
that's what they call her first lady
that's what it is
I thought I just said that wrong but I
mean instantly hopes not based on the
first lady it's not based in the first
man it's not guys it's just not there
y'all and you know if you don't like
that I can help you with this change of
the channel say this is one of those
things it's a Dave Ramsey show thing so
I believe in Christmas that's hope that
is real hope and if you don't believe
that I'll still be your friend I'll
still help you but if you want me to
change what I'm saying on my show that I
own you're gonna have a problem cuz I'm
under the illusion I own it and 12
million people sign up every day to
listen and hang out with us and if you
if we want to be just one less than that
we'll be alright
we can live without you it's okay not
mad at you but you're not gonna tell me
how to run this thing and you're not
gonna tell me where my hope comes from
because I'm a hundred percent sure it
comes from nowhere near the vicinity of
Washington DC I'm a hundred percent sure
of that and it comes a lot closer to a
manger in Bethlehem Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas you know it's okay y'all
it's okay if you want to be happy
something else then be happy something
else I'm okay with you we'll still be
friends I'll still help you with your
money if you want me to but if you're
mad at me cuz I said Merry Christmas
then then go find somebody else to help
you with your money and it's okay to
I'll still be okay and you'll still be
okay we gotten so torqued out managing
other people's business in this culture
spend all our time telling somebody else
how to live and you even got your own
act together oh my goodness a lot of
work that takes a lot of energy so open
phones this out as we talk to you about
your life and your money it's a free
call and some say the advice is worth
what you pay for it and some don't agree
with the messenger and so be it
such is 25 years on the radio see
some of you disagreeing with me I got
socks older than you so it's okay it's
gonna be okay it's gonna be all right
we'll work it out together hang out with
us
triple 8 8 2 5 5 2 2 5 you can follow me
on Twitter if you want to stir it up
that's where it's always stirred up at
Dave Ramsey and of course you can follow
us on Facebook there's about 800,000 on
Twitter I think there's about 4 million
on Facebook when they decide they want
to let us have for me and they change it
about every week it's 4 million but they
don't let us talk to all of you once
because they have an algorithm they just
mess with everything so facebook.com
slash David but there's a lot of good
content stuff there now I do the Twitter
account the team here and social media
team runs the Facebook accounts so if
they put something on there that has a -
Dave Ramsey it means it's something I
said but I didn't type it out on
Facebook cuz I don't even know how to
get on Facebook
now my wife quite different I'll just
tell you that but anyway so merry
Christmas to you glad you're here thanks
for hanging out with us and try it real
hard
be happy it's Christmas time this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]